all right so I did have emergency
appendix removal late last week very
early in the morning but late last week
and it was not fun and big thank you to
Pat for filling in for me and for
handling the bonus shows and getting the
shows out and even doing a few stories
on the Friday show he did a really great
job in rolling with the punches the
whole team did in fact and incredibly at
the Wednesday show I did suffering from
appendicitis without even knowing it and
I had woken up but to 3:00 in the
morning with just like high stomach pain
every couple of hours during the night
and when I woke up in the morning it got
worse and it started moving down into
the right which is pretty typical of
appendicitis but it could have been a
number of other things I did the show
and then I decided to go to Urgent Care
and at Urgent Care they they didn't
really do much they just like pushed on
my stomach and said if it was
appendicitis it would hurt more you
should just go home and rest which I did
and by the time that a few hours had
gone by things just did not feel right
so I went to the emergency room at
Brigham and Women's Falkner Hospital
with my girlfriend got there they did
some tests and it was after doing a cat
scan it was very clearly appendicitis
and before I knew it they had a surgical
resident talking to me and saying you
should really remove it we could try
antibiotics but it's not you know it's
slower it could happen again
well you really should have your
appendix removed and by this time it
must have been close to midnight
absolute chaos at the emergency room and
Falkner hospital it was actually great
the the experience of something that was
terrible was made a lot less bad by the
great care that I received but just to
give you a sense of just how crazy it
was the number of people that were
needing to be restrained by security and
I mean he was just an example of what
was going on just right next door to
where I was in the emergency room
yeah and it just went on and on with
people saying they didn't want to be
held there against their will and you
know just absolute in total chaos listen
[Music]
yeah so anyway that was what was going
on well the surgical resident was trying
to explain the procedure to me and at
one point I think she said you know the
anesthesiologist is going to come talk
to you soon and I think I vaguely
remember saying that's not the
anesthesiologist is it and it was a
light-hearted moment in the middle of
what was otherwise not not a fun day
so things I mean it was like all night
eventually you know the anesthesiologist
showed up we talked about the plan
I met the surgeon and here's an
interesting story by the way about the
surgeon the surgeon comes in and I find
out that the surgeons specialty doctor
matinees who did a great job he
specializes in endocrine surgery and I'm
thinking back you know not that long ago
I read the checklist manifesto by dr.
Atul Gawande
here and who's a great doctor here in
Boston who also specializes in I believe
it's endocrine cancer surgery so I said
to my doctor do you know Atul Gawande
and he said yeah we share an office
actually and one of the last things I
remember when I was sedated already with
very strong valium which is great great
great stuff if you're anxious I've high
medical anxiety mmm this stuff works I
remember being in the o.r and everybody
going through in a way that was
reminiscent of what Atul Gawande sort of
developed and writes about in the
checklist manifesto going through what
is each person on the o.r teams what is
the role of each person in the room who
is the patient what are they doing I
remember actually saying the last thing
I remember is it seems like everybody's
read the checklist manifesto and I
remember people in the room laughing and
then waking up in the recovery room
and it was like an hour procedure it
went as well as these things I think can
go every day I've been getting stronger
still not back to to full strength but
it was not a fun experience I think 7%
of the population
ends up having their appendix removed
from what I was told and I don't wish it
on anybody but I'm glad that it was done
and so far so good a lot of people
tweeting me saying what am I going to
end up paying I don't know the answer to
that as many of you know I pay 420
dollars a month for my health insurance
which is okay and many of you know about
my $800 podiatry visit a few months ago
I've looked up that the the procedure I
had not including like the emergency
room component just the procedure can
range in the u.s. from 1,500 to 180,000
dollars now I'm guessing that there are
other factors that affect that price
other than just where you have it done
the average cost of an appendectomy is
$33,000 so far all I've gotten is the
cat-scan bill which was billed at 368
dollars my insurance has graciously
negotiated that down to 302 but they pay
none of it because I have not yet
reached my annual deductible of $2000 so
my approach is I'm sort of preparing for
being told I have to pay my full
deductible that I'm a no $2,000 for this
it could be more it could be less we
will see but glad to be back and
hopefully just up and up from here but
not a fun couple of days and thanks to
everybody who wrote in and said get well
soon well wishes and all of that stuff
it really was great hearing from people
and we've got some voicemails coming up
later related to this as well